freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher kopf
lang lang ist s her und es ist nicht nur
eine neue folge ein persönlicher koch
sondern ich will mal wieder in einer
fremden küche und zwar in der vom lieben
marc eggers kann man rein
es ist dein auftritt ich stehe heute ein
tag den komment für dich deine
einstellung zum kochen also man sieht
schon ich habe jetzt nicht die größte
küche ich bin auch echt ein bisschen
beschämt dass ich dir so was ihnen liege
da mehr oder weniger als persönlichkeit
nehme ich natürlich auch die
herausforderung einer kleinen kirche an
wie das ja gerne gemütlich mache ich
rede jetzt rasch für die mit nutella
weichert wird dein lieblingsessen ist
eigentlich nutella brot machen wir mal
eine andere version heute losgeht so da
stehen wir also ich habe mir meine
kleine eigene kochte mitgenommen damit
er mich auch gut sehen könnt ihr beim
kochen ich habe hier vier bremsscheiben
liegen wer es nicht kennt ich habe ja
auch schon mal für den stoff gemacht
einfach ein super weiche französisches
brot damit macht man auf jeden fall
schon mal nichts falsch süßes frühstück
markt so das ist eine gute grundlage
damit das ganze zu einem franchise wird
braucht man natürlich noch französisches
brot sondern wir müssen auch ein wenig
milch auf einen teller geben zwei eier
dann gebe ich daran ein bisschen sind
wir nutzen keinen zucker besondern
junkie flavour mit salt carroll
geschmack kann ich mal gucken wie süß
der ist das kann man doch nicht so
richtig erschrecken weil das so boards
ist eher süß geknallt richtig dafür dann
packe ich mir eine kabel und der verkehr
dann ganz vorsichtig und wenn man unsere
mischung hier vor das ist wirklich eine
sehr entspannte nummer hier verein ist
in ein weilchen für sich schön voll
saugen das ganze ich bin ja so sehr
einfach gestrickt wird kochen angeht
aber das sieht jetzt für mich so aus als
ob selbst ich das interessant ist gast
in der pfanne bis 2000 war sie einmal in
eine mischung aus milch eiern zimt und
zucker beziehungsweise süßstoff einmal
durchziehen vollsaugen reinlegen
auspacken werden superreichen sondern
dazwischen so eine schöne geschichte das
team schon zu rufen was das frühstück
erst und damit es dann wirklich ganz
gesund ist noch ein paar alibi wären wir
ganz besorgt dann wären wir das ganze
mal jetzt kommt in die mitte natürlich
nach schöne geschichten und hat schon
schwierigere sachen in der kindheit sag
ich mal so aber ins gedicht gut aussehen
ich glaube gut schmecken wird auf jeden
fall dann bin ich doch zufrieden so ich
hab hier darum jetzt noch ein paar reden
was auffällt dass du so eine beere
mischung bekommen was ich habe nicht nur
glück gehabt du sogar absichtlich
gekauft kraft natürlich mit glück
gekauft haben wir das ding was soll ich
dazu noch sagen beim esstisch ist ruhig
berichtigt man setzt sie hier auf dem
boden bedürftige ist bei mir zu hause
ist es genauso wie sitzt auch immer auf
dem boden bei der franchise oft von max
danke machte das frühstück
die wirklich da ist auch gerne hört
diese dummen wächst dafür nicht bekannt
mit no job schmeckt echt
runde bezweckt sehr gut also wirklich
egal wir sehen uns gleich wieder zur
bewertung eines fensters erklärt
avanciert ich habe ungebetenen besuch
bekommen aber wieder auf und der ist
auch ausgehungert er bleibt nicht mehr
gästen vier tage ist nicht mehr aber du
bist auch der erste der jetzt direkt
anfängt das obst damit auf zugabe
alles aufgegessen mag das ist ein gutes
heißen erst mal ich bin gespannt hat es
ihr geschmeckt also wirklich ich bin
nutella liebhaber aber in dieser combo
schön warm french toast mäßig also jetzt
wirklich aber auch nur weil es mit dem
teller hättest du das jetzt mit
irgendwelchen anderen sachen gemacht mit
marmelade das so dann wäre das ganz
anders gewesen aber die ihr frühstücks
technische mich zehn von zehn ohne
rizzello geyer besser kommen wir zum
mittagessen uns war es bei geht die
carbonara mit frische nudeln wir haben
wir haben pecorino parmesan pauschale
wir haben keine reise deshalb werde ich
jetzt einfach ein bisschen kreativ hallo
felix hast du vielleicht schon die web
gelesen kann da abholen wo du rettest
mich ich war gerade schon am schnitzen
mit einem messer ganz zu werfen fragt
man
monsanto ist wer private werde ich geht
dahin dass gibt so schieben geschafft
[Applaus]
ich werde gerne wieder hoch
ist eine käserei personaler mit sahne
das haben aber ohne sahne zu die sich
auf unser spiel davon schwer das kann
ihr am besten man nicht schon so
beeinflusst dass ihr könnt mir den fuß
sohle hinlegen wie vor ist die lage
so wir machen den hertener auf budapest
fand sich gerade da gehen wir hier
unsere mentale streifen hinein es zieht
sich jetzt eben noch ein bisschen
zusammen dann wird das wiso chips aber
es ist unglaublich hier seht was hier
für höhe und war von der kontra lernen
unsere frische nudeln legen wir ihnen
geben mir einfach mal in den top genannt
durch japan getrennt wir brauchen
nämlich nur das eigelb für unsere
kameradschaft ein wenig müde wasser
abweist das bestimmt moodle was hat ganz
viel stärker an den nudeln und deshalb
findet die soße die wir jetzt machen
werden ich finde das halt immer weg dass
unsere wasser das ist schade weil dann
kann so vielen aufmachte einmal gekommen
ja ich habe schon mal einmal für mich
ist ja nicht kochen ich mache da
irgendwie zwei drei babys in den ofen
und fertig so weißt du sondern kochen
das ist kochen und das dubeys in gruppen
zubereitet bevor rudel anklemmen denen
wir ein wenig corino wenig parmesan oder
eigelb und nach und nach etwas
nudelwasser dazu nach und nach damit das
eigelb nischen zu verbinden wir das
ganze und das hier ist eine klassische
carbonara soße daneben will das von der
guten start und auch ab diesem zeitpunkt
wird auch sowieso nicht mehr mit hitze
gearbeitet reicht passiert die magie so
ich schneide die kommentare chips und
sich den klein und war bis jetzt weil
neben den rest werde ich dann immer so
zum an richtung übergeben und jetzt
kommt die auszeichnung geben wir uns
jetzt schmilzt aber von der
rechtsschütze an den nudeln zentralbank
ezb ist müde wasser ist okay sind kann
dann auch noch im sound reden die
thermik ganz okay dann anrichten oder
würde ich auch sagen man ist fertig und
dann darf der markt schmecken wirklich
gespannt was zu sagen dass du deine
ersten authentischen habona
irgendwas eigens nach wien gekommen
das ist eine ganz andere welt
okay leute ich glaube das reicht schon
wenn man uns eine portion fertig und
dann sehen wir uns zur bewertung die
carbonara hatten wir sehr gut gemundet
und ich muss wirklich sagen ist war die
beste carbonara man fühlt sich so in
keiner schuld weißt du kochst hier gibt
es die so viel mühe und dann hat man das
gefühl man muss was positives sagen aber
das was ich hier sage es wirklich vom
tiefsten herzen und es war die beste
carbonara die ggs nach wirklich darauf
müssen wir noch mal
ein nein nein und wir haben eben schon
darüber gesprochen ich gehe auch echt
gut essen er kocht zwar nicht so viel
aber ich bin würde ich auch gerne in
guten restaurants und will auch sagen
dass ich mit technischen bisschen ahnung
habt und kann beurteilen dass das für
mich
ist die wahrheit ist ich bin ich bin
gerne weil wir hier richtig spaß aber
das abendessen haben wir tatsächlich
schon vorbereitet und wie seht ihr jetzt
so kommen wir zum abend ist ist es nicht
schön wir haben ganz ganz viele zutaten
die ganz ganz viel geschmack geben wir
fangen aber an indem wir unsere chili
schnappen und die erstmals von ihrem
stamm befreien und dann die kerne
loswerden sonst wird es richtig laut
die ganzen spiele aus und hier haben wir
jetzt nichts als die schale corsi und 12
kerne sind drin aber das ist ja auch ein
bisschen schärfe das natürlich auch amt
für die geben wir einmal auf den herd
ist im wasser auf das ganze kurz einmal
aufkochen bei ab in den nächsten
natürlich sind auch gekauft und sind
wieder am leben jetzt machen die
herdplatte aus und füllen das ganze in
einen mixer ganze mit ein bisschen extra
wasser
unterwegs
hier habe ich das gleich für unser chili
con carne sich nicht lumpen lassen wir
haben zwei richtig schöne rumpsteak
sowohl die schneiden wir jetzt einmal
den würfel schneiden sich die butter und
finden sie sehen auch richtig gut aus
jetzt brauchen wir den großen topf und
machte indirekt mehrheit zu geben wir
ein bisschen öl hinein bei dazu bereit
dich jemand zwiebel vor wenn wir hier
ein bisschen temperaturen gehen wir
unser fleisch hinein und das system zur
besserung oder so die anderen 70 50 mark
in die top 20 jetzt wirklich direkt
fragen
jetzt geben jetzt drüber
selbst option das fleisch heraus auf
jeden fall ein bisschen farbe bekommen
jetzt ist das meiste eigentlich schon
erledigt jetzt geben darunter mit der
temperatur eben unser fleisch hinein und
gegeben und die chili
möglich da ist so viel geschmack drin
einfach weil es wird jetzt gleich wenn
der deckel drauf ist einfach noch
einkaufen geht dazu jetzt noch ein wenig
kakaopulver wohlgemerkt natürlich
ungesüßte ist also back auf war sieht
noch ein wenig zimt und zu machen so
lassen wir das ganze jetzt köcheln für
minimum eine stunde aber wir fügen dann
noch was wir machen jetzt die beilage zu
unserem chili con carne das ist einfach
nur 250 gramm couscous und auch 150
gramm kostet schüttet man 500 milliliter
wasser fest dass fünf bis zehn minuten
ziehen das war es einfach es gibt es
nicht mehr das was er jetzt auch braucht
gucken wir mal gemeinsam in den topf
also man sieht schon bis konstanz bis
hier oben jetzt ist das ganze so weit
runter reduziert man sieht schon dass
hat so ein bisschen körper da gehen
jetzt zuallererst mal bohnen und mais
ready punkte da bin ich bin eher
skeptisch dadurch dass die anderen
sachen so gut geschmeckt haben kann sich
eine gut werden aber da bin ich gar
nicht sicher ob nicht das überzeugt
[Musik]
also optisch seht ihr selber sieht man
selber gerade weil ich das ist gut sie
haben mir dass ungleichheit chilli con
carne verkauft es waren hat mich
wirklich an das gute courage von meiner
mama
ja aber nicht
schmeckt sehr intensiv also man merkt
diese ganzen sachen die da drin sind es
ist anders als wie ich chilli con carne
kenne bei den anderen sachen wollten die
richtig sichert hier bin ich ehrlich
aufgeregt und ob ich zu recht aufgeregt
bin wirklich gollasch kommt chili zum
abendessen
was sagst du dazu die schärfe technisch
hast du mich zu 100 prozent abgeholt ich
mag scharf aber auch nicht zuschauer und
da kann man so viel falsch machen wenn
ein essen zu scharf ist und jemand das
nicht mag ist das ding ja durch ja dann
kannst du es nicht genießen aber die
schärfe war wirklich zehn von zehn war
richtig gut es war wirklich ganz anders
als wirklich chilli con carne kenne ja
irgendwie nicht so dieses klassische ja
was ich aber auch extrem liebe deshalb
fällt jetzt mein ranking ein bisschen
schlechter aus ich glaube dass ich eher
die person chili con carne bin so wie
ich es kennt so das klassische wäre aber
trotzdem auf jeden fall achteinhalb von
cz also weit sei es das ist bombenleger
das ist wohlgemerkt mein erster versuch
und ich finde ich geb dir vollkommen
recht man mehr das ist ein selbst
gemachtes chili con carne ich werde
obwohl es noch
ein halbes absolut geld freue mich dass
wir immer wieder eine folge alltag wir
sind ja co hatten danke dass du dabei
warst du was einen war zwar gastgeber
aber du warst auch mein gastgeber es war
auf jeden fall ein sehr angenehmer tag
mit dir und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
check mark aus bis dahin
[Musik]